[Music]
sorry to hear about your loss thanks
Roger I'm so sorry mr. Dodge
thanks Linda so sorry if your about your
loss thanks it yeah yeah I'm ok ed right
now your path looks pretty bleak
your Ma's dead Nikki we've decided it'd
be best if your auntie came and stay for
a while
[Music]
hate to go over all ground
I'll get explained what happens when I
have a breaker house they're gonna take
what they want didn't leave this what
you think just terrible terrible tragedy
sorry I'm buck Cooper insurance claims
investigator I'm here to discuss your
sisters powers been as busy as long as I
have you develop a nose for hanky-panky
it's got this faint aroma but this case
you know this one stinks I got to tell
you that kind of nonsense I can hunt you
down the road if you killed her I mean
this is a safe place it was
welcome to suburbicon a town of wonder
and excitement I'm
[Music]
with the promise of prosperity for all
isn't it time for your new star are you
into the MA for money it's falling apart
Mei
[Music]
come home do suburbicon oh you no doubt
for a ride
[Music]